- [Narrator] Humans need
dentists. It's a fact.
In 2017 alone,
Americans spent $129
billion on dental visits,
and an estimated 90% of adults
in the US have fillings.
But many animals don't have this problem
because they can regrow their teeth,
replacing old damaged ones
with brand new pearly whites.
Wouldn't it be great if you could do that?
Well, there's actually
an important trade-off
for this nuisance.
Only a handful of mammals can
regrow teeth multiple times
compared to the 50,000
species of reptiles and fish.
Take geckos for example.
They replace all 100 or so teeth
every three to four months,
and since geckos can
live for six to 10 years,
they'll grow anywhere from 1,800
to 4,000 teeth in a lifetime.
That's all thanks to a special
type of cell in their gums
called stem cells.
Stem cells are handy because
they can morph into different
cells when needed,
like tooth stem cells to build new teeth.
Humans have these stem
cells when we're younger,
but after our adult teeth grow in,
the stem cells die and disappear.
To understand why, let's
take a journey back in time
to about 320 million
years ago when mammals
and reptiles split off.
In addition to many obvious differences,
another change that eventually
emerged was tooth shape.
Reptiles, for example, are
what's called generalists,
meaning they eat the animals
they can get their teeth on.
And for that, they needed teeth
with the same size and shape
to keep prey from escaping their mouths.
Mammals, on the other hand,
developed more specific diets,
like grazers who only eat
grass and hunters who rip flesh
from their kills.
As a result, mammals evolved
different-shaped teeth
for different purposes.
And it's this difference
that could also explain
why mammals can't regrow more teeth.
Now, let's say you could regrow
your molars multiple times,
for example.
It's important that the top
and bottom sets match up.
Otherwise, they can't
grind food as efficiently.
That sounds good in principle,
but with each new set,
there's a risk that the
regrown teeth won't line up.
So the leading theory is that
adult humans can't regrow
our teeth because it
was better for survival
to only grow one well-aligned adult set.
However, if you still wish
you could regrow a tooth,
there may be a way in the future.
Using lasers and drugs, scientists
have helped rats and mice
regrow damaged tissue
in cavity-ridden teeth
with the idea that if you
could regrow tooth tissue,
you could eventually regrow entire teeth,
though no human testing
has been done on that yet.
So keep flossing and
keep seeing your dentist.
At least for now.